وفي طهران الحث المتحدث باسم خارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني حتى حكومتي بغداد
واربيل على العمل لضمان امن الحدود مع
ايران
منطلقا لاي تهديدات ضد امني ايران القومي
انه ينبغي ان لا تسمح اربيل لمن سماها
جماعه الانفصاليه بتصدير السلاح الى مثير
الشعب في ايران بهذا في زعزعه الاستقرار
فيها الحديث
هذا وقد نفذ حكومه اقليم كردستان انباء ان
تداولتها مواقع ايرانيه تحدثت عن تهريب
اسلحه عبر حدود الاقليم الى ايران وقال
المتحدث باسم حكومه اقليم كردستان جوتيار
عادل ان تلك الانباء عاريه عن الصحه وان
الاقليم لم ولن يسمح او يفسح الطريق باي
شكل من الاشكال للعبه بامن اي دوله جاره
عبر اراضيه
عن المسؤولين عراقيين انا ايران هددت بشن
عمليه عسكريه شمال العراق اذا لم يحصل
الجيش العراقي حدوده مع ايران ويمنعوا
تسلل جماعه المعارضه الايرانيه الكرديه
وفق ما ذكرته الوكاله